What are the systems issues, in managing
large data centers? How do you program big
data applications, such as search engines, to
run on massively large clusters? How do you
store and disseminate content on the web,
in a scalable manner? Hello and welcome back.
These are the kinds of the questions we will be addressing in this module of
the course. This is what we mean when we use the term internet scale computing.
A comforting factor for you is that
you already know the answer to these questions.
We've learned through the previous lessons, most
of the techniques needed in constructing distributed services.
What we're going to see in the
upcoming lesson, is a hardening of the distributed
systems issues to handle scale on the
order of thousands of processes and failures.
It's not a question of if. It's a question of when a failure's going to happen.